Every single one of you, by voting conscience,
that's how you change things.
You change things by voting for who you believe
in.
This is a celebration, I think it is just
the start of a really big movement,
the Libertarian movement.
I don't feel like the fact that we voted for
Gary caused that to happen.
It was not a vote for Trump, it was a vote
for the right thing.
It was not a protest, we were voting for the
right guy.
I have friends who are on both sides of the
pole.
My Republican friends tell me 'Hey, a vote
for Johnson is a vote for Hillary.'
My Democratic friends tell me 'Hey, a vote
for Johnson is a vote for Trump.'
And what I say to them is 'A vote for Johnson
is a vote for change.
It's a vote to put a third party on the map.'
The day after the elections is gonna be a
big hang over for America
and a lot of people are going to look at us Libertarians
and say 'You caused this. Your vote, you threw away your vote.'
and I'm going to say back to them 'No.
'Cause I can look back 20 years from now and
say I voted for the Libertarian party
because of what I believe in and what I stood up to.'
The people who voted for Trump are responsible
for a Trump presidency.
So I think that, in the primaries, that was
where that decision was made.
I think the Libertarians have their own voice
and they speak for themselves.
And so I think that the results that we are
seeing tonight
is basically the results of a very, very flawed system.
A very flawed debating system too, as far
as the presidential debates go.
And so I think that these deficits have to
be accounted for somehow.
There is a phrase that I like to hear, any
gambler likes to hear it.
It's called 'covering the spread.'
And if you look up on that map that they're
showing on TV, you'll see a lot of states
where Gary Johnson covered the spread.
And there's gonna be a lot of old party politicians
whining and crying tomorrow
about all the votes they should have had.
Well you know what I say to that?
Your tears are delicious and your parties
will die.
If you want our votes, if you want to win
in America,
then you have to deal with the issues of the racist war on drugs.
You have to deal with the issue of our 20
trillion dollar national debt.
You have to deal with a country that no longer
wants to send it's sons and daughters overseas
to die in other countries' civil wars.
And if you don't deal with those issues and
if you don't address Libertarian issues
then you will lose.
Get used to it.
Do you regret your vote knowing what the outcome
is now?
No because I don't think that us voting for
Hillary would have been any better.
We voted for the candidate that deserved to
win.
We voted for the man that should have been
our president.
Two days from now, who did you vote for?
Two months from now, who did you vote for?
Two years, twenty years, always hold your
head high, all of you, you absolutely rock,
thank you very very very much for being out
here and supporting this campaign.